c'est le son du bonheur cette petite
chose à mi-chemin entre un gremlin et un
canard et le jouet le plus convoité de
l'année
conséquence à chaque livraison de
furbise dans un magasin voici le
résultat des files d'attente des
restrictions à l'avant de plus d'un
Furby par personne et une fièvre
acheteuse qui gagne tous les continents
ce l'objet de leur désir coûte seulement
35 dollars soit 200 francs en magasin
mais Furby est tellement difficile à
trouver qu'il se négocie parfois à 6000
francs sur internet un phénomène de mode
mais aussi le premier jouet d'un genre
qui va conquérir le cœur des enfants
un compagnon de jeu surtout comme un
bandit pas disponible pour jouer
on peut dire que ça va de la première
génération qui vont être confortables
avec les robots avec les machines
robotiques bientôt compatibles avec un
ordinateur l'atelier du Père Noël et lui
aussi entrer dans le troisième
millénaire